Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
So, yes, I am back.
Sorry for like the last stream.
I did say I will end the stream instantly when I beat the level, guys.
I did say that.
I didn't lie.
When you come to the Dogeybird stream, I never lie.
Hi.
Look, I was just really happy, okay?
I knew it.
I knew it was the frames.
The moment I unlocked my potential, I first tried it technically.
The moment, the moment I was like, my eyes, my eyes was just so used to seeing things at 240 frames that like the moment is past 60 frames.
I just unlocked my hidden potential.
Maybe I'm just secretly a gifted rhythm player.
It just needs to be above 60 frames.
It was the eyes.
I can't see anything below 240 frames, guys.
I just can't.
I technically first tried it, if you think about it.
Think about it.
I don't remember the second half of that game.
And then I was able to technically first try it, plus one.
I have specialized.
I require the maximum amount of frames for the maximum amount of potential.
That's why, that's why, that's why, that's why I'm the FPSV tumor.
I told you.
I told you it was frames.
People were like, Doki, you're just coping.
It's not the frames.
I knew it.
This is absolute proof that like, your eyes can see above...
Every time people are like, um, the human eyes can't see above 30 frames.
This is my proof here.
Yes, it can.
I couldn't get past the 054 second mark.
The moment it was above 60, I went past it.
I...
This is my vindication.
I am living proof that eyes can see above 30 frames.
I have become more than human.
I...
Anyway, guys.
So today, we are gonna be playing...
I don't even remember the game's name.
I have...
It's called Promise Mascot Agency.
I saw this game...
Yeah, I overclocked my eyes.
I am the next form of evolution.
Anyway, as I said, I saw this game on Steam.
You know, like, it was like, uh, was it like new and trending or whatever?
I was like, oh, what's this?
And, you know, I was looking for new games to play.
Because I like trying on new things, you know.
Um, since I can play whatever the fuck I want.
And, um...
And, uh, I saw the reviews.
The reviews for it were...
Was actually, like, incredibly promising.
Uh, so, wait.
Let me read some of the reviews.
So, people were like, oh, don't judge...
Don't judge the book by its cover.
Because it was like, you know, the game that...
I was reading the description of the game.
And it was all, like, incredibly weird.
I was like, okay, a lot of this sounds incredibly weird.
So, I was like, hmm.
And I read the reviews.
And everyone was like, oh, this is such a good game.
You have to try a...
Like, the more you play it, the more you'll, like, come to love it.
So, I was like, okay.
This seems pretty interesting.
It seems like a really interesting game.
It's like an open world.
It's open world.
And you're trying to start, like...
It's sort of like starting a YouTuber company.
But instead of starting a YouTuber company, you're making a mascot agency.
And I heard that, like, it is very addictive.
And, like, the story is really, really good.
And it's only...
Apparently, it's a 15-hour gameplay time.
Which I thought was very surprising for an open world game.
But at least that doesn't mean...
At least I won't be playing it for, like...
For, like, a year.
Just like Dynasty Warriors.
At least...
So, it's more so you're starting, like, a VTuber company.
But instead of VTubers, you're starting a mascot company.
So, yeah.
That's, like, the whole premise of everything.
And I just thought the reviews...
Everybody was glazing the hell out of it in the reviews.
So, I figured I'd give it a try.
Lord Kurosis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I am from the next forum of Evolution Shays Doki.
The one that's sick every other week.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It is the sacrifices I must make.
Okay?
I sacrifice my health for better frames.
And I think it's a good trade.
I was able to beat the Demoman level.
I just can never go outside or take a vacation outside of my country.
Or I get sick.
But that's okay.
I can see more than 60 frames.
Solid Snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Your ending instantly actually worked out for me because...
Because me break from work was finishing.
So, I take this.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Eating.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Pokemon, but for adults who like business and make money.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's check this game out.
Clean.
I mean, they all look the same.
Default.
Default looks...
Oh, wait, there it is.
Okay, there's open dyslexic default.
I actually like the clean more.
Like, what the fuck is this?
I'm sorry.
Like, I can barely read it properly.
High contrast style log.
What's that do?
Style one.
Oh, it's just the color of it.
Style five.
Off.
Uh, most likely, maybe I do black just for, like, just for people who can't read like me.
Uh, yeah, just do black.
Fuck it.
It's just easier to read.
I don't need a note.
I just make it easier to read for us.
Vintage color.
Prime is intended to play into a vintage camera filter to enhance the nostalgia feel of a Showa-era town in Japan.
You can disable it if you prefer.
What does it look like?
Oh, I didn't know!
I was like, I thought it would show me a preview.
Okay, um, let me swap it.
I thought, okay.
Okay, I can fix this.
Um, oh, wait.
Where was it?
Where's the vintage?
Oh, no.
Where's the, where's the vintage?
How do I turn vintage on?
Next step on evolution.
Where's, where's the vintage color processing?
Accessibility.
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
Um, all right.
There we go.
I did it!
No!
I was like, oh, what does it look like?
I...
Okay, no screen shake, please.
I hate screen shake.
I, I, I honestly think screen shake is, um, makes the game worse.
Uh, all right.
Chaseable animal speed.
Uh, let's see.
Color correction.
Accessibility.
General.
Oh, yeah.
We have to use...
Apparently, if controller is best for this.
Controller is best for this.
All right.
Also, sound guy.
Lower the music and bring the game up a good amount.
All right.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Okay, I'll bring that up.
Let me know if it's better.
Sound guy.
Uh, silly bird.
And the menu.
Pause fight.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
15 hours, but open mode.
So, you'll get lost and take down all of that.
Okay, that does sound like me, though.
Uh, all right.
Graphics.
Is there...
As long as there's no motion blur, I'm fine.
I gotta make sure there's no motion blur, guys.
Borderless frame rate.
You know what that means.
Unlocked potential.
Okay, maybe not.
Maybe not.
120 frames.
Uh, okay.
Get the motion blur off.
Zero.
Oh, my screen's gonna be weird.
Okay, the intercom person heard me say, Yippee.
I, like, answered the phone.
I was like, Yippee.
Let's...
Let's them in.
They might have been like, What the fuck?
Okay, um...
I forgot I'm streaming here.
Um...
All right.
I think everything...
Everything should look good.
Uh...
Rush, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You forgot the outro earlier.
We're all...
It's okay.
You can drink after this stream.
After this stream.
Guys, don't worry.
You'll drink after this.
All right.
Promise mascot agency.
This mascot reminds me of that...
What's her?
Cheetan?
The one that's, like, everywhere?
And, like, does, like, the crazy shit?
All right.
I love, uh...
This is a work of fiction.
Yeah.
That mascot reminds me of Cheetan.
If you...
If you say Cheetan three times in the mirror, she'll appear behind you.
Welcome to the world of mascots.
Mascots are...
We're born from the earth a long time ago and live alongside humans.
We've got everything humans have.
Feelings, problems, questionable biology, and an existential fear of a beyond we can't comprehend.
Some of us also have weird abilities.
Or...
Oh, I love exposition dump right here in the menu.
My mom was a fairy mascot and my deadbeat absentee father was a severed finger.
So inherited a little...
Oh, wait.
Is he a toe?
Wait.
That's a fucking toe.
Wait a minute.
I just realized the top part is a fucking nail.
A little bit of sparkly magic and an inner void.
You're about to enjoy a wonderful summer.
In a cursed town.
But first, you need to see what's happening in Japan's underworld.
Okay.
Anti-Yakuza laws are strangling the crown families of Japan.
The lions in Kyoshi are struggling to survive at home.
They're plagued by squabbles between subsidiaries on the border of the territory.
Hiroshima's fair...
Oh, I'm getting like a free Japanese lesson right now.
In my mascot game.
Meanwhile, in Tokyo, the Hara Federation adapted and now commands a vast business...
Are you guys taking notes?
It's going to be on test later.
Leave in mind small-scale criminal activities.
A deal has been brokered between Kyoshu and Tokyo.
By paying a tribute of 12 billion yen, the Nakamura Alliance will ally with the Hara Federation, gaining access to your business contacts and protection from the Fujiwara Syndicate.
I heard like if you work in Japan, you have to like...
If you work in Japan, you have to like...
Legally sign a contract that says you don't work at the Yakuza.
If you want to work like a normal job in a company.
In a matter of hours, the money will change hands and new oaths will be sworn.
The future of every crime family in Japan will be decided on a sweltering summer night in Fukuhara.
Yeah, because you know, that's illegal.
I don't know if you guys know this, but like...
The Yakuza is a criminal organization.
I had to legally tell people that you do not work for the Yakuza.
Wait, it's in Japanese.
I mean, it makes sense.
I'm in Japan.
You know, it's like how you're playing a game in like France and they're like speaking in English.
And you're like, what is speaking in English?
Wait, that makes sense.
No, I'm in Japan.
They should be speaking Japanese.
How dare you?
Why would they speak my language?
Also, let me check in my...
Oh, they put my ice cream outside my door.
Oh no, give me a sec.
I need to get my ice cream.
My ice cream.
Alright, I was like, wait a minute.
This is taking a while.
To like move to my area.
Alright, it's outside my door.
I got my s'mores.
My ice cream.
Yeah.
Alright.
The boss of the Shimazu family.
A brilliant leader who dreams of...
Um...
Of uniting the warren class of Kyushu.
So if anyone can do it, it's her.
Alright.
I locked him out.
It's just ice cream.
I know you can't eat ice cream.
I can't change the settings right now.
It'll be after I finish the narration.
Okay, maybe this will put an end to all the infighting the alliance, eh?
We'll get all the family head in line and stop the squabbling.
Alright.
The fifth chairman from the same bloodline.
An aging Yakuza boss who's losing his grip of power.
The scariest Yakuza.
Those who manage to live this long.
I mean, that's true.
Because they haven't been murdered yet.
I want personally thank the lieutenant for conducting the exchange.
Okay.
I know.
Guys.
I sort of don't really want to read too much.
So like, is there an English dub?
There is an English dub to this game, right?
You'll join us at the banquet.
It's because I'm lazy.
Okay?
Respectful or...
He's not going to be the leader in the end, right?
So I can be differential.
Thank you for allowing us to represent the strength and grace of the Nakamura Alliance.
The janitor?
Wait.
That's not even like...
It's still respectful.
How was I not respectful?
And the most feared enforcer in all of Kyushu.
His legends precede him.
Don't judge a book by its cover.
Especially if...
I mean, he looks...
Okay.
He looks like a very scary teacher.
He actually...
Kiryu's VA?
Oh, I was just indifferent.
I mean, I still sounded very respectful to him.
Wait.
Who's the VA of him?
Who's Kiryu?
I hope we can serve you in a manner that makes you happy, sir.
He just looks like a scary gym teacher.
I end up actually...
I end up actually playing Yakuza.
Oh, it's that good man.
It's this one.
You two have quite the reputation.
The janitor and his proji.
Maybe you'll forge your own legend as well someday, young Tokihira.
Oh my god.
What is it called?
I'm not actually playing Yakuza, but it is Yakuza technically.
Second-hand Yakuza.
I'm just happy to learn from my Oath brother, sir.
The face of modern Yakuza.
Stylish Yakuza.
Michi's Oath brother and rising star in the Shimazu family.
Oh, modern Yakuza.
Legally destroyed.
What the fuck is that?
The exchange of Tonki.
Is that the...
The penguin?
Oh my god.
This is what he looks like outside of his penguin suit.
He looks like that...
Isn't that like the...
The chain?
The penguin chain?
Um...
Keeping it nice and small.
And Incognito.
Just these two.
They're going early.
All gorgeous-like.
We'll make sure this goes off of a hitch, sir.
Donkey.
He has two...
Wait.
Is that the toe?
Oh my god.
It's the other...
It's the dad.
The absentee father.
Liz by his coat of honor.
Born without mascot magic or cute looks.
He has to make his life...
His way through life on hard mode.
Shimasu's right hand finger.
Well, I won't keep you any longer.
I'll see you all at the banquet.
So it's like...
We have like our own...
Oh.
Arigato gozaimasu.
So it's like...
Each Yakuza family has their own like mascot.
They're like...
It's like their stands.
It's like their Jojo stand.
Hello?
How do I start this game?
Oh, okay.
There you go.
Okay.
Let me fix this.
Um...
Audio.
We turn it to 100.
Turn the music down to 20.
And then...
Put the voice up a little bit.
Alright.
I need to know.
Is it actually all...
Okay.
Actually open font options.
I need classic.
I need clean.
I can't...
It's actually all...
In Japanese.
Because...
I would prefer not to read.
Okay.
I guess it's reading time.
I...
I thought...
You know...
I had my ice cream.
And I was like...
Yeah.
I can't wait to eat my ice cream.
And listen.
I gotta read, guys.
It's reading time.
Alright.
Okay.
It's reading time.
The meat point is just up ahead, boss.
Oh, shit.
I played...
Sorry.
I'm still in the Simpsons hit and run mode right now.
I want to eat my ice cream while I play.
But I have to read.
Act 1.
Dreams of the future.
Oh my god.
There's twins.
There's evil twins.
This Yakuza has everything.
I wish I ordered a mini and not a small.
I can't believe we're meeting the hair of Federation.
You're beating up truck.
What's wrong with him?
Yeah.
We have to be discreet.
We can't let people know we're the Yakuza.
If you say so.
Keep your eyes open.
Something doesn't feel right.
That's right.
I shouldn't be covering up my tattoos.
It's a simple job.
And Don makes sure only we know about it.
Besides the big scary janitors here.
Oh, I'm annoyed.
Yeah.
We gotta teach this young one a lesson.
That's right.
He's gotta respect me.
I'm the senpai here.
Enough chat.
The hair of Federation will be here soon.
Oh, oh my god.
Aniki.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Guys, he calls me Aniki.
All right.
All is forgiven.
Oh.
You Shimazu little kids?
Cheap shirt and counterfeit watches?
Those look like Fujiwawa syndicate men.
Oh, he wants to leave.
I closed the door on him.
Oh, that's why he's growling.
He's growling at me to open the door for him.
Because I closed the door on him.
He's like, I am telling you to open the door.
I didn't realize that.
Like, in a moment I opened the door, he like went outside.
He wanted to leave.
No, he wanted to leave.
I don't care who they are.
It's time for them to leave.
All right.
Fight me.
You're off the leash.
No rules tonight.
Now, before they draw their guns.
That's right.
We're going to fight.
Show them who's boss.
Freedom.
All right.
Fighting sounds.
These guys are monsters.
This isn't working, bro.
They're too much.
Enough.
Come here, pretty boy.
Just try it.
I think they're actually saying, Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, shit.
He got a gun.
Who brought a gun to a...
Oh, my God.
They all got guns.
Okay.
Maybe I shouldn't have fought them.
Playtime's over.
Any more noise on YouTube?
And the next bullet is in his head.
Don't listen to the boss.
Kill them.
Protect them.
That's illegal.
In my legal fight.
Okay.
It's all right.
He can...
Like...
Look, he disrespected me.
So, like...
Ah, do I...
He did call me Anaki, though.
Okay.
He did call me that.
So, I'll be nice.
Let him go.
Janda isn't so tough after all.
He has feelings.
That's right.
We don't rely on guns.
We use our brooms.
Stop calling me Anaki and I will.
This won't be happening.
I'll get a real nice promotion if I bring this pretty head back to the boss.
Let him go.
We won't stop you from taking the money.
You have my word.
Nani?
Your weakness is family after all.
Pathetic!
Let's kill them both.
Let them run back to the mother and tell her that they lost the alliance's money.
It'll be more fun to watch the Shimizu family destroy itself.
Let's go.
No!
My money!
I don't understand.
This is still about mascots, right?
Why you let them leave, boss?
They destroyed us.
You're right.
I spent 20 plus years raising this boy to be a mass murderer.
Not for him to die right now.
We didn't raise you to get killed by some coward from the Fujiwai syndicate.
You're the future of this family.
That's crap and you know it, boss.
It's actually really hard to raise a good Yakuza soldier to live long enough to be their age.
I'm the one in charge here.
I'll take that fall.
The boss and the rest of the family will need to help.
You need your help to fix this.
The force acting is really good.
I could feel it.
I don't know what they're saying, but I could feel the emotion.
You're my oaf, brother.
We started to protect each other above all else.
Let's get you back home and patched up.
Boss.
Alright.
A short while later.
Sorry, we lost...
Wait, he has abs?
The fuck?
Why are you taking a fall for this?
Oh my god.
That's a ripped-ass finger.
The boss needs...
He's been doing lots of thumb wars.
The boss needs to sacrifice me to protect the rest of you.
It's been a privilege to serve with you, Toki.
Now go, and wait downstairs.
That's an order.
Demo!
What?
That's enough, kiddo.
Get in there, Michi.
Fate's waiting.
Hello.
Oh my god, it's the twins.
This was supposed to be the most important day in the Shimazu family's history.
But you let 12 billion just disappear into the night?
I wasn't going to allow someone from the Fujiwara Syndicate to put a bullet in the head of one of our best.
The Nakamura Alliance doesn't care about Tokihira's life.
They care about the money!
The hare federation came to the Fukuroka, Fukuroka, Fukuroka, Fukuroka expecting a warm welcome and a banquet.
Instead, they turned up the bloodstains and no money?
It took me a while to say that.
Most likely, dad's hungry right now.
But I need to wait for 30 more minutes.
We got there as early as planned.
Everything was on time.
No one saw us.
The Fujiwara ambushes before the hare federation arrived.
They came armed and shot Tokih.
It was his life or the money.
They never come this far into your territory before.
This was unusual for them.
We weren't ready.
The Nakamura Alliance trusted us with their funds and reputation.
And now it's all gone!
They're out for blood.
News has already spread throughout the Nakamura Alliance.
Some families have issued orders to seize our territories as compensation.
It will only be a matter of time before the Fujiwara take advantage of our infighting and move on to Kiyoshi.
Thank you.
That's right.
Go submit.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy Good Friday, my fellow Canadians.
I understand.
Noe, please.
Pass me your knife.
This ain't the 80s anymore, kid.
I'm missing pinkie ain't gonna fix this.
She doesn't care.
She's like, let me cut the pinkie.
Just above the knuckle.
Push down.
Hard.
Wait, are we actually cutting my finger?
Oh, shit.
Please accept my sincere apology.
You picked me up off the streets.
I swore an oath to you.
Wait, so he cut off his fingers for no reason?
They don't even care.
It's not me you have to apologize to, Michizen.
Kiyoshi is going to have to fight the Fujiwawa invasion with the support of Tokyo.
Oh, my pinkie's gone.
You see it.
He just... but it was fun for him.
I assumed that this is my last night alive.
Just waiting for the order, uncle.
Her blade.
Oh, my God.
Wait, she doesn't have feet.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, I just noticed that.
Look, she's like the... the kingsman lady, girl.
Remember that king?
Oh, my God.
She was so cool.
Okay, not her, but that... the kingsman lady.
Where, like, her... like, her feet was just like that.
And, uh, she can, like... she can swap it to poison blades.
That's so cool.
One of Shimazu's adopted daughter.
A blade in the night, a blade in your throat, a blade in everyone you love.
Whatever mother's needs.
Oh, wait, the other one... you can tell...
Guys, guess which one is which, guys.
It's like...
Am I Hikaru or Karu?
Guess which one is which.
Is it the one with no feet or the one with feet?
They look all... they look practically identical.
Mother's dream hangs by a thread now.
We looked up to you, uncle.
One of Shimazu's adopted daughters.
And a future sociopathic genius.
Proficient in fraud, extortion, and geopolitical desivilization.
She sounds like a fun girl.
Um, there's a lot of ways to break a person and she knows...
Oh, I can fix her.
Maybe she can fix me.
I...
This is the end of so much, Michi Zane.
Our way of life is over.
Honestly, I feel like she's gonna fix us, guys.
Sounds like time's up, uncle.
Hold still.
Wait, is Tokihira still outside?
Nah, he's downstairs waiting to pay his respects to the corpse of this guy.
Good.
No one but us can know about this.
The Shimazu family isn't finished yet.
I have one last job for the janitor.
Oh my god, it's my...
It's my VTuber company!
We have...
Sorry, my V mascot company.
We have one last business that...
Uh, the Nakamura Alliance can't seize.
Yes, they don't know about it.
What company is it?
Good.
Same thing.
A mascot in Disney.
You're gonna clean the company up, turn it around, and make us the money we need to keep the knives from our throats.
You sure this is a good idea?
A VTuber company at this day and age?
It will have to be...
Sorry, it's a little bit...
A little bit too relevant.
A mascot agency?
Where is it?
A little bit too real.
Have you ever heard of Kasomachi?
A Yakuza.
It's so trivial...
He's still trying to strike trap...
Of course, the town of gods and demons who curse any male Yakuza, who dare to set foot there, granting a slow and painful death.
My knife sounds kinder, mother.
The curse that hangs over that town will train the life from you, giving enough time.
It's a bad way to die.
We'll have to deceive everyone for now to buy some time.
You'll be reborn in the cursed town tomorrow.
Ready to start repaying our debts.
I'm faking my death to become a CEO of a mascot company?
Holy shit, that's hardcore.
Prepare a body bag.
We'll make sure everyone sees a janitor's funeral processions.
Drive him to his grave in his beloved truck.
The time I got reincarnated and became a CEO of a VTuber company.
This is a second chance, Michi.
If it were anywhere else, they'd be dead by now.
You fell again?
I'll kill you myself.
I'm determined.
Don't worry.
I will make the next VTuber company.
I won't let you down, boss.
Your dream won't die.
I promise.
I am sorry, Michi Zane.
My optimism got the better of me again.
And now you'll die in the cursed town.
Not before I've done what you need me to.
And then she put me in a bo- Oh, look, she put me in a body bag right here.
Aw, they all pay respect to my fake dead body.
This is your idea of a family?
One mistake and we're fed to the Nakamura Alliance?
I'll never let my talents graduate.
Or else.
Toughen up, Toki.
We are Yakuza.
Death is a part of life.
Say your goodbyes to yesterday and do it quickly.
It's a new era.
And we've got work to do.
What will happen to his body?
The cycle continues.
Holy fuck.
Okay, I did not expect this game to be- I thought this was like a cheery mascot agency game.
If I knew, I would not schedule this game this week.
The city will see his corpse.
They will see when we take our transgression seriously.
Michi Zane and the Legend of the Giant will be forgotten.
Will I take over his position?
No, you were there too.
If you didn't need- If he didn't need to babysit you, he wouldn't be dead.
Babysit?
Stop being a damn child and get to work!
Yes, boss.
This place really is the town of the dead.
Let's get this body bag to the agency.
We can get the bottle of tea when we get back to civilization.
Oh, that's me, Kroki.
Here I am.
Whoa.
Wait, do those like- Oh look, there's like- Oh, take your uncle's body bag?
What is it- What are those, um...
Raccoons called again?
Tanookis, right?
They're- Oh look, you can- They're accurate too.
You know how it's- Wait, is it- Yeah, is that the-
You know the lore about Tanookis, right?
You- I just wanted to see if they're accurate.
Okay, no they're not.
This is- They're not.
I thought it was something else.
So...
Um...
This is the sensor Tanooki.
So Tanookis are supposed to have-
The lore of Tanookis is that they're supposed to have giant balls for some reason.
Uh...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
They're not- They're not accurate Tanooki models.
Yeah, they're not raccoons, but they're- I'm like- I'm like thinking about raccoons when I see Tanookis.
I have no idea why the lore is like- The- The lore is like that, but- That's all I can remember about Tanookis.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
I hope it can fly with them- Holy shit, this town loves Tanookis!
Oh my god.
There's a lot of them in this town.
Welcome to the town of the dead Yakuza.
Oh wait, no it does!
Wait, wait- Wait, wait!
Wait!
Wait, what's that?
Wait a minute!
The spirits came for you!
Wait, there they are!
There, nevermind.
This one was particularly accurate.
Like...
Whoa.
Alright, anyway, let's go.
Let's try... I thought this was a tycoon game.
Look, we're getting there, okay?
We're getting to that part right now.
I just had to look at the Tudukis.
Alright.
I'm just driving to get to this new home.
Where's my new home?
Oh, Yanhao.
Wait, is that a love hotel?
Hotel promise.
You had to?
Look, I just wanted to see if it was accurate or not.
Welcome to your new hotel.
Your new home, uncle.
Yeah, I was gonna say, that's a love hotel.
If you're recruiting mascots...
What the fuck?
Why am I putting them in love hotels?
Are they gonna fuck the mascots?
What?
Wait, we'll return with further instruction.
Further instruction?
Guys, I don't think I'm making a VTuber agency anymore.
What?
I'm making a different kind of agency.
We need money.
The Nakamura Alliance lost a fortune because of you.
You use this agency to pay that money back.
Once you establish a business, we'll come and see you.
If you don't earn enough money, mother will be killed by the bosses from the other families.
I understand.
Are you guys...
Are you girls walking home?
We're meeting Don outside of town.
Take care, uncle.
Oh my god, it's my Chi-tan!
Pinky-tan!
Come on!
Be nice to Pinky.
She's our friend and you'll need our help.
Pinky?
I'm the Lutuber manager now.
A cursed town.
Why are we all meeting up outside my love hotel?
I don't... I don't...
Oh my god!
They have the different...
Why is this mascot operating a love hotel?
A lonely room for one?
Yes.
Just me.
Look, I can love myself.
Don't judge.
That's not what I'm here for.
I need to speak to me and my...
Okay, that's the worst.
Oh my gosh.
Pay up or get out.
The self-service machine is broken.
So just hand me the money.
There's an ATM outside if you need cash.
I'm the new manager of this dump.
You gotta be kidding me.
Wait there.
Nani?
Who is this guy?
Does it sound good already?
Jack is on his shoulder.
Like some kind of...
You think you got what it takes to run a love hotel?
You think this is an easy streeters?
Oh my god.
Now I know what she reminds me of.
That show.
The something pop something.
You know the two girls?
Pop Team Epic.
Yeah.
Now I was like...
This reminds me of Pop Team Epic.
The finger is giving me a middle finger.
You make me sick waltzing in here like you're hot stuff.
I'm not here to take over your love hotel.
Michi is really toying the line with this girl.
Not so thankful.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, it's a pinky.
The dad's the thumb.
I'm here to run the mascot agency.
And you're standing in my way.
What did you say?
I'm here to do my job.
You can either help me or get out.
Holy shit.
I'll kill you.
Why is Kiryu Kazuma here?
Um, no.
It's, uh, I'm Michi.
You're tougher than you look.
I'm guessing you're not coming after this business solo.
Who sent you?
Who did you say your boss is?
I'll be frustrated at her.
I'm the boss.
I must not show weakness or submissiveness to her.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Michi needs to tiptoe around this one.
Obviously.
I didn't get the chance.
Quit whining.
Just tell me who should I be expecting next?
I might do that in the next place.
Let's treat.
I don't need this.
I'm not gonna laugh.
What?
I don't wanna laugh.
I'm gonna laugh.
I've been looking after this place.
Failed mascot looking for... Oh no, she failed... She failed her VTuber career.
She wants to re-debut.
She wants to reincarnate and re-debut here.
Hasomichi Machi hasn't treated her well, but she's ready to make dreams come true.
Maybe this will be a good day at the office after all.
I'm going to help her re-debut.
Don't worry.
Come on.
I'll show you around, boss.
I'll turn you from a 1 view to a 10 view.
Right then, boss.
What's your name?
Everyone calls me by my first name.
Michi.
Michi as in...
The janitor?
So much for lying, Nolo.
How do you know that name?
I can't believe a fellow violence-liker is my boss.
I'm looking forward to learning a lot from you.
You'll be like the dad this girl never had.
What?
Oh, she has daddy issues already.
Oh, this is perfect.
So what brings someone like you to the town of the dead?
Is the janitor here to clean things up?
I made this mistake, and I've been sent here to atone for it.
What is this uptight?
What happened?
I know about your world.
Give me the deets.
The Nakamura Alliance were going to hand over a huge sum of money to the Hara Federation as an exchange.
I was supposed to be in charge.
The Fujiwara is going to get ambushed us, and I had to choose between the money and my Oath's brother's life.
You must have really messed up if she sent you to a town with a curse that kills Yakuza, dudes.
Hang on, did Nui and Yui bring you here?
How do you know Nui and Yui?
We go way back.
We used to hang out here.
At the Love Hotel?
That's not where kids should be hanging around at.
What the fuck?
What?
Just chilling at the Love Hotel?
Why don't I know that?
I used to come here in secret.
I don't know why.
Anyway, we got something in common.
Both abandoned.
Both abandoned the cursed town by Donki.
Yeah, I can see the thumb.
Is Donki your father?
Who would bang a thumb?
Wait, how are...
Wait.
That means they can bang each other?
I can see the resemblance.
Matriarch Shimazu took me in.
And Don was always there to guide me.
She glad.
Glad he was a father to someone.
He took off and abandoned me here years ago.
My mom was a fairy marshmallow.
I got her eyes and squishy body.
Just got the bad attitude from my dad.
Loyal?
What's...
Apologize...
Sorry...
That your dad's fucked up.
I don't believe that.
Don has always been good to his family.
That's the key.
Why did I grow up fatherless?
Maybe you were just a bad daughter.
You were just a dumb lady.
Oh my God.
Who said that?
I was like, I mean, look at you.
Oh my God.
The dad was ashamed.
He was like...
He was like, I thought you looked like your mother.
Not like me.
Because he hates how he hates himself.
So he's like, every time I look at you, I'm reminded of myself.
I can't believe Shimazu sent you to this dump.
How much did you lose anyway?
12 billion.
12 billion?
Are you an idiot?
I love the voice acting.
It's so cute.
You can't put a price on family, you say, to a finger that has daddy issues.
Yada, yada.
Good grief.
Fine.
Whatever.
Why does this have to happen to a nice girl like me?
Anyway.
Down to business.
Oh my god, she's wearing like a little business tag called Pinkie.
That's cute.
The first stitch is that Mary Meida has forbidden us from doing business on Kiso Machi.
Why?
I don't know.
Own messed up, probably.
He's very uptight.
Uh, I'm curious.
I'll be imploring.
You need to tell me.
We're working together now.
Yeah, I shouldn't have threatened a little girl.
Wait, why did they leave?
There's only one mascot agency here.
Fine.
He hired a mascot agency for his granddaughter's birthday party.
But all our mascots had left, and so I did it.
He took my mascot license?
I know this is a surprise, but I'm not a people person.
Things happen.
He refused to...
What did you do at that child's birthday?
He refused to pay up and rescinded the mascot agency's business license.
Wait, so I have a love hotel license and not a mascot agency license?
Is love hotel licenses that easy to get compared to the mascot agency?
So that's why this is operating as a love hotel.
I feel like that'd be harder to operate.
Sounds like when you see the mayor so you can apologize and go get our license back.
More importantly...
Let's talk cash.
How much you got?
None.
Zero.
What are you doing?
Where are they?
Oh, grief.
The agency account is empty.
Wait, who's paying the bills?
So we're bankrupt.
Who's paying the...
Who's paying the fucking electricity bills then?
If Meitra's Chimazu believes in you, I believe in you.
I've always been a sucker for dreams.
Chimazu's dream, my dream, your dream, the dream of the mascots we're going to employ.
Let's make some come true!
Alright.
We're gonna make some dreams come true, guys.
We're gonna start your VTuber career.
Somebody must love pinkies.
Nice to finally have some wheels!
I'll take... I'm doing all the driving then?
Stop complaining!
Get moving, Point Dexter!
That's all we need in life.
A man, his finger in his truck.
If you're ever unsure about what you should do next, open up the management menu.
I'm your new hot secretary!
I'll put your to-do list in there.
The button prompt for the management menu is on your HUD when you're driving.
Press that thing!
By the way, you got a phone on you, right?
No, I don't like them.
Why are old men like this?
Fine.
I'll handle all the phone calls and messaging people.
You just look menacing and drive us around!
Finally, I got a secretary.
I never have to answer Discord messages again.
The mayor's over at the town hall!
Head down the hill and cross the river!
It's the place with the flags!
Don't worry about it being early in the morning.
That old fool wakes up early, shows his face at town hall, and then drinks in the afternoon.
Alright, it's not that far.
Now let's go clean up this town!
Okay, I'm finally beginning my redemption arc.
Okay, how do I get there?
Okay, give me a sec.
Is there like a map?
Like, how do I... I guess it's this way?
I assume it's the red, right?
Yeah.
Alright.
Yay!
It looks like someone's credit card and...
A thousand and seven hundred.
It's just straight down this hill and over the bridge.
Yay!
I'm glad people forgot their wallets.
The mayor's a crusty old geezer and he hates everyone.
I can't wait to meet him.
Alright, it's this way.
So it's across the bridge.
I assume I have to go this way, right?
Wait, can I break through here?
Fuck.
Okay, I can't.
Whoops, sorry!
Sorry, Pinky!
I thought I could smash through the fence.
I didn't realize that's not allowed.
I assume that's where the mayor lives.
With a giant poster of himself?
Okay, whoops, sorry.
I thought I was hit and run.
Yeah, that has to be.
With a giant poster of himself.
What happens if I get in a car crash?
Oh, nothing.
Okay, that's cool.
I'm glad that nobody cares.
Oh my god, this mayor has pictures.
Wait, is that where all the money is at?
Wait, this guy's using our tax...
Our taxpayers' funds to put posters and statues of himself everywhere.
You ready to apologize?
I guess.
We need this to get the business going again, Pinky.
Yes, mom.
Don't start that!
Just throw your pride away!
We have a dream to achieve!
Whatever.
Do not mention my history, nickname, or matriarch Shimazu.
We need to keep this as quiet as possible.
Whatever you say, boss.
Don't be like that!
Fine.
After you!
Thanks!
She got me Socho!
Oh my god.
First Anaki and now Socho!
Oh my god!
You got some nerve showing your face here, Pinky.
And who the hell is...
She's so easy.
I am...
Just the little things make me happy.
Despicable man that has ran Kasomichi into the ground for his own gain.
Vote for Meida and vote for Misery.
How the fuck did he get nominated?
Oh, Corruption.
I am the new manager of Mascot Agency.
Didn't even need to finish it.
Pinky isn't the waifu you wanted, but it's the waifu you deserve.
We've come to apologize for Pinky's previous poor business practices.
And to graciously ask for a Mascot Agency license to be reinstated.
Marisho, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You need to throw your pie away.
Yep, that's a VTuber manager, alright.
Shogun...
It looks like...
He does look like Mere Sanders.
No chance, this little freak ruined my granddaughter's birthday party.
Huh?
What did you say?
Oh my god, he's such a great manager.
That's how my manager talks for me if I'm angry.
If I'm mad, I type up like a really angry response to my manager.
And then he makes it sound nice and polite.
What Pinky meant the same.
Is that we are very sorry for any past inconveniences.
And want to ensure that they never happen again.
Hear me now.
I apologize for what happened at your granddaughter's party.
I shouldn't have said what I said or put the knife where I played it.
Oh my god, that is such a PR response.
Unlike the white document.
I am not good at...
I am not good at being a mascot or a company representative.
But with your permission, I'd like to improve and become a better person.
Would you graciously let us conduct business again?
Why?
It's a worthless business with zero potential.
Especially with you running things.
YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG YANG Y Put them in a love hotel.
You have no hope.
Don't worry.
I can make them beautiful.
I can make that one view into a ten view.
Anyway, why is there such a thug in my office?
You're clearly a Yakuza and I can't be seen with the likes of you.
I have a reputation to uphold.
Whatever my previous life may have been, I can assure you that I am nothing more than a humble mascot fan and inspiring entrepreneur.
Pinky and I wish to work together to make a profitable bonus that benefits Kasomachi.
Such prejudice against tattoos.
No, it's just that if you're in the Yakuza, you happen to get like a specific tattoo.
And like it's like easily recognizable too.
So like like Yakuza members have like tattoos that are like you can tell it's you're like you're a Yakuza.
Next thing, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They're my weirdos, tramps and freaks.
Yep, sounds like typical VTuber fans to me.
Thank you for the super chat next to you.
Thank you.
Marshall, thank you for the super chat.
Weedos, tramps, and freaks.
Yep, that's a VTuber agency.
All right.
Nonsense.
I'm not letting some thug and a failed mascot run a joke I'm an agency in my town.
The same brain cell.
You know what?
They'll only understand threats.
He's scared of me because I'm part of the Yakuza.
Let's get to the point.
I assume that you're looking for a payment from us?
If you're allowed to have a business license, we'll cut you into proceeds after we start receiving work.
See?
I know how a corrupted politician works.
All they care about is money.
I am a surprise...
I played Schedule 1, guys.
I am surprised a thug and an idiot could be so savvy.
Here's your license.
It's under Pinky's name.
I can't have any record of me giving a business license to an ex-Yakuza.
Thank you for your support, Mr. Mayor.
Thank you for your support.
I love Pinky.
Thanks, Your Majesty.
I love Pinky already.
She is...
She is prime peak waifu material.
Are you really gonna give him kickbacks?
I'll deal with that later.
What's important is that...
We're back in business.
I'm sure he'll come see us, to...
Come to see us about it.
What do you mean she's not waifu material?
Look at her!
I want a fancam of Pinky to tomorrow.
By the end of tomorrow, guys.
Don't worry.
His thugs are nothing compared to the janitor.
I like her, but she is a pinky.
You don't deserve her.
Don't call me that here.
That's my old life.
Fine, we need to head back to the office.
I need to do paperwork to reopen the agency.
No one knows we're open for mascot jobs yet.
We need to put the word out!
What about recruiting mascots?
We'll deal with that after we got the administration out of the way.
Alright, let's get moving!
Alright.
Yay!
We got our business license!
As long as we don't let Banky host birthday parties!
Alright, let's go home.
And open our business, guys.
Open our VTuber agency.
And make those dreams come true!
Alright, we're official now.
Wait, there's like a comp- Oh, oh, that's nice.
I can bring out the map here.
What's this?
Oh, I can change my POV.
I can be like super immersive.
Yeah.
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Okay.
I was not expecting that.
Wait, what?
Oh, wait!
I can jump?
Jump?
I can jump too?
Wee!
Oh my god, my truck jumps!
I have Nitro.
Okay.
We're almost back in business.
Just one last field to enter into the registration site.
What are we calling this place?
It used to be called Kaiso Machi mascots, but then I changed it to Hotel Promise when things went south.
Oh, that's good that they won't let me name the company, because I would name it something fucked up.
Then we'll call it Promise Mascot Agency.
We have to fulfill a promise to matriarch Shimazu and the mascot in this town.
I have formed the mysterious masked figures at the Mascot Ranking Association in Tokyo.
Mysterious masked figures?
I was gonna name it...
I was just gonna say Black Company.
I was just gonna be the name of my...
in my mascot agency.
They're the unknowable, esoteric god beings that run the mascot ranking.
Continue the cycle.
And hold our lives in the palms of their onyx hands.
Watch the top of the screen.
Do you see that?
I just rebanded the Life Love Hotel social media to Promise Mascot Agency.
We got some new fans.
We have new fans already?
Did they hear... did they...
Oh my gosh, wait, I need to feed Doki.
What do you want to do?
I'll be right back.
Alright, I'm back.
I need to feed my dad.
Why did Love...
Yeah, why do I have this...
Why does a Love Motel have a social media following?
Probably people that married early fantasize of things they could be doing in a town their partner doesn't even know the name of.
Wait, what?
Are they coming...
Anyway...
Each time we do something, I post an update and people with nothing better to do share it around.
And we get new fans.
Wait, are they bots?
Like what do you mean like people share around and we get new fans?
Like are they...
Are they bots?
Are they real people?
Don't worry.
I didn't mention your name.
The rest of the world still thinks you're dead.
I can assure you that you're definitely not the face of our online presence.
We're trying to make this a success.
The amount of fans we have determines our fame level, which determines where we stand in the mascot ranking association's popularity chart.
The higher our fame level, the more people know that we're serious.
And more opportunities will open up to us.
So keep gathering fans by doing good stuff!
Alright Pinky, start a YouTube channel.
She can be my manager streamer!
She can be my manager for my other VTubers!
And then she can have her own channel!
We're all ready to go and make some dreams come true.
And then I can make merch off of her!
And she gets paid the regular salary!
Of like, a manager!
And I get to take the entire cut of the VTuber part!
Of the channel!
What about your dream?
Oh my god, she's my P-chan!
Wait, that's not very appropriate.
Not been asked that in a while.
I want to run an agency and become the town mascot!
Maybe send off some of my rougher edges and bring some joy to this dump!
What about becoming mayor?
Me?
I don't think I'm cut out for political office!
Devious?
Wait, I want to know what devious is!
Don't worry, we'll murder him later!
Ha ha ha!
Our lives will be easier without mayor and Meida.
It will be easier to make money!
Oh, look!
See, Pinky's down!
I told you!
She's the wife we deserve!
You've got a good point!
Get yourself a waifu that commit murder for you!
Are we gonna kill Meida and bury his body in the woods?
She's so real!
No!
We'll see if we can improve this town.
The nice guy wait first!
I just want you to know that I'm ready!
She's ride or die!
She's perfect!
For what?
I'm burying a corpse in the woods!
I've been putting a body in a car!
And driving up to a brutal spot!
And Grim Silence is really bonding!
No name!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
A vote for Doki is a vote for...
It's a vote for progress!
Just something I've always wanted to do!
I suppose that's number two on the dream list!
Just keep it in mind!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh, she's a little freaky!
I like that!
Feel free to take a look around the agency!
And leave when you're ready!
Actually, I almost forgot!
Let me paint the eyes of this Aruma!
Tradition and all!
Oh!
Oh yeah!
It's a Japanese tradition!
That's cute!
You're supposed to paint the eyes at the beginning of doing something big!
But nothing big has happened until today!
This is the start of the promised mascot agency then!
Aw!
No, Pinky!
The hangnail stays on!
Papa Smurf!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I know!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
This feels good!
Life has some promise now!
Return to the agency!
Oh, I got 150 new fans!
Everybody's so curious about my love hotel!
Alright!
Okay, so we don't have anyone to recruit!
Do we have any jobs?
Do we have anything?
Jobs?
You haven't had any offered jobs?
Upgrades!
Okay, we need to explore to find upgrades!
Relax!
I have one room in this love hotel?
Like...
Oh, maybe like...
Oh, that's the freaky room!
Where it's out in the open!
I see!
This is the...
This is the particularly freaky one!
Um, cause...
Why is this so dirty?
Um, Pinky can't really take care of herself!
Oh, can I like...
Oh, I can change nail design!
Oh!
This is like...
Wait, what is it called?
Style?
It's just like Pinky's nail style!
The foyer room!
Oop!
What's next?
My show, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Wait a second!
A game set in Japan?
An intro that takes hours with tons of dialogue?
Some kind of cute mascot?
Is this Persona?
I think like this is like Persona and Yakuza mixed in together.
I somehow accidentally played a Yakuza game.
After like everything I said about Yakuza.
We need to get us a mascot!
There's other stuff as well, but most importantly, we need some employees!
Where did the old agency employees go?
And then the money dried up!
They all left!
They always get you.
There's some mascots in this town though, right?
Oh yeah!
Some don't know when to quit!
Others want to stay in their hometown!
Lots of...
Oh yeah!
It's Yakuza light!
Because it's like only 15 hours!
Lots of mascots have abilities like...
Turning different colors!
Levitating!
Staying calm under pressure!
And so on!
We don't got none of those in this town!
Well, I can absorb an impact like a mother hecker!
But no one's breathing fire around these parts!
So we're gonna make do with...
With?
I don't want to say dregs!
So let's just say misfits that can't get any other work!
Don't worry!
I'll polish those misfits!
I'll make the next Kizuna!
How do we recruit them?
We'll need to find them!
However, I put that word out online...
So maybe we can sit back...
Sip cocktails...
And wait for them to come to us!
Eh?
Oh my god!
She sounds so cute!
I'll have a martini!
Oh my god!
She's so cute!
I like how...
Cactus...
Deleted all the Kizuna...
When I made the reference to Kizuna!
Cactus was like...
No talking about Kizuna!
No!
I mentioned her first!
Hello!
I'm reaching you!
I see you no pinky!
Hello!
Nice to meet you!
Oh my god!
Tofu is so cute!
She's gonna be a star!
I can see it!
She's gonna be a fucking star!
Currently soft, but wants to be firm.
Never stops crying, but that's part of...
Wait, his charm?
Wait...
Treated badly by punks, but that needs a good kicking?
If you ask...
Wait...
He?
I don't know...
Can we help?
It's so perfect!
We can make it work!
Better!
I saw online that the...
Asuka Agency is open again!
You bet it is!
This here's a new boss!
I think he's killed people!
Oh my god!
She's so cute!
What?
I love it when he's scared!
Warning!
This tofu might contain nuts!
Golem, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Golem!
Pinky is just a bit overexcited about the Agency being open again!
See?
Pinky, you made our guest cry!
Don't worry, I love it when they cry!
They're so cute when they're crying!
It's okay!
I'm not crying because of you two!
I just...
I can never stop crying!
Tofu and I go way back!
We used to go to school together!
They're in there so cruel!
Pinky...
Some kids used to give us crap until I found out where they live!
What brings you to see this day, Tofu?
I'm gonna make you a fucking star, Tofu!
I saw that Pinky posted that the Agency was open again!
And well...
My therapist says I need to try new things!
And...
You've come to the right place!
You wanna get out of here and meet new people and make them happy, right?
Um...
I'm not sure...
I don't know, he's so cute!
So...
Thank you to the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
My name's...
Not Pinky!
If your dream is to make a difference in people's lives and crush old men under your boot, we're here to help!
Wait!
I'm not sure about...
Look, we'll give you a salary and a room to stay in!
We can offer more as well!
Tofu, my new cameoshi!
Hey!
Wait a minute, Tofu, you're fired!
No one encroaches in my territory!
Boss, let me explain how this works!
What a mascot like Tofu goes out on a job, they take a percentage of the payment for the job as their wage!
If jobs go well...
The clan pays more and everyone earns more money!
When you recruit a mascot, you can choose what percentage of the job payment they'll get at the end of the job!
Obviously, they'll be happy with a higher percentage, but the agency will receive less!
I will watch Tofu!
No matter where they reincarnate, you'll follow Tofu wherever she goes!
You can offer your mascot more perks like tied-off and guaranteed bonus reviews!
We're employee-centric, so you need to work to make them interested in working for us!
Now, we got places to be!
Let's look at the paperwork!
Alright!
You need to convince- Well, I didn't really do much to convince Tofu!
Each mascot will get a share of your money you receive for every job to complete!
But you should offer them extra perks!
The more you convince them, the happier you'll be!
But remember that you can't take the perks away later!
Alright!
Okay!
Until you complete your non-increasing job share!
Um...
Every six, negotiate a bonus!
I'll give you time off!
Okay, what happens?
Board...
I'll give you...
Okay, so...
The bonus...
Alright!
That should be fine!
I'll give...
Actually...
I'll give you a bonus!
And...
Actually...
Job share...
Can be...
Can't be set...
Non-increasing...
What is...
Non-increasing job share can affect stats?
What does it do?
What does job share even do?
It's a bonus a lot?
Okay, well...
We'll do 5% then.
There we go.
That's enough.
Time off and...
5% job share.
Alright!
Here's my offer, Tofu!
Make offer for 17% payment from jobs to complete plus the selected perks.
Once recruited...
Tofu can be managed from the...
Alright!
Nice!
Look!
See?
You got 17%!
That's a lot!
That...
Just think about it.
Uh...
Okay...
It might be a little tight...
But...
You're doing this as a hobby, Tofu.
Just remember that.
Like...
You're only doing this to make yourself happier.
And isn't like...
Being a mascot the happiest thing you can do?
Will?
Just think about that.
Think.
And then like...
You know...
Maybe when we get merch later...
Your...
Your percentage will increase, Tofu.
Please treat him better.
I'm ready to work whenever you want me to send out.
And think about it.
You're gonna make so many fans so happy.
You don't want them to be sad, right?
You wanna make them happy.
Tofu deserves better.
Thank you for agreeing to work with us.
We'll do our best to achieve all of our dreams.
Head into the industry and make yourself at home.
Shiori will come and get you when there's a job.
Shiori?
Last time I saw, she said she put me in a hotpot!
Zofu Tajis won't keep our voices down.
How did she...
How does you already have a fan name?!
I'm sure she meant that affectionately.
Go and chill out in the office.
The rotating beds will kick your mind off everything.
Thank you.
Thank you again for this opportunity.
Look, see?
He's grateful.
He's grateful for that 17%.
Okay, boss.
It's the first day of the rest of our lives.
We recruited our first mascots, so we're almost ready to start sending them out on jobs.
Who is Shiori and why was Tofu scared of her?
My fellow Tofutachis!
She takes the mascot out on jobs and runs the events.
She seems scared because of her temper, but she's cooler than most people in this town.
Ancho, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Say firm Tofutachis!
We will defend our king!
For she works at a convenience store over the river.
If she works at a convenience store, how can she take mascots on jobs?
That won't be a problem.
Let's go!
Head back down the hill into town again.
But at this time, hang a right and go across the blue bridge.
Remember to head for the red icon on your mini-map.
And you're not sure where to go.
Okay.
That seems easy enough.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, is it there?
That's so far!
Alright, let's go.
I need to go this way.
Okay.
Alright, we gotta find...
We gotta find...
Find the staff member.
Alright, can I do a shortcut?
I think I can, yeah.
Yay, jump!
Wait, there's something up here.
Oh, it's just trash.
Woo!
I feel like I'm gonna have to collect trash somewhere.
Later.
Okay, I assume it's...
Okay, there's the blue bridge.
What?
Yeah, I know.
Why didn't you tell me about the map?
I know where I'm going.
I'm just taking a shortcut.
Woo!
Alright, I'm here at the market.
Hello!
Hi!
Hey Pinky!
Oh, she's wearing my shirt!
Or are she?
Oh my god, we're already making money on merch.
Must be Michi, the new boss.
But to me, you...
Word travels fast.
Wait, how does she know?
Can't believe I'm finally meeting a janitor.
Yeah, how does she know?
I'm supposed to be dead!
Does everyone here know my name?
I'm gonna call people.
Don't worry, boss man.
I'll keep your secret.
I'm tight with you and you.
While I keep this hella quiet.
Of course, you keep thinking about the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Shari is one of our employees.
Well, our only employee.
I used to work for Pinky.
Before she converted the place into a love hotel.
Back when there was a work for mascots.
Alright.
She'll handle your mascots or die trying.
Angry at a small town.
Metal as heck.
A human ship missile who could change the world.
On a money drive up?
I came to work in the convenience store.
There's no way I can clean up a love...
Okay, yeah.
Like...
You gotta be paid a lot of money to clean up a love hotel.
That does not seem like a great job.
Even like regular hotels is pretty neat.
It's a lot.
Shari is our mascot handler.
As soon as Pinky messaged me to say the industry was back in business.
I flipped off my manager and walked out.
I'm ready for work, boss man.
My destiny is to work with mascots.
Not sell two day old Odin to the creeps in this town.
So we got lots of work.
Loads of mascots that need my foot up their ass.
The crusty old mayor just gave us her business license back.
We're just about to speak to some potential clients about some work.
Right on.
I'll go and get some stuff in order and get ready for the call.
Mascot support heroes?
Wait, what is that?
Yeah.
Check it, boss man.
As well as being a mascot handler.
I'm a registered mascot support hero.
Fighting a child?
Vehicular homicide?
What kind of mascots do we have?
Look at that.
I told you Tofu might be a murderer.
When that happens, you need to send heroes to help them.
Slend it!
My Tofu would never!
If you choose to help, you use heroes to give your mascots a boost thing to get through a bad time.
Hey, you should become heroes as well.
Okay, I'll be honest.
I'm supposed to be dead.
That's as honest as I can be.
I'll do it!
Right on!
Remember, each hero has different strengths and weaknesses.
I'm gonna find as many heroes as you can!
Ask around town and go- Oh my gosh, I'm basically getting handlers right now.
Ask around town and go searching for more hero cards.
You never know where you might find a card!
Running a mascot agency is stranger than I thought it was going to be.
Whoa!
Oh, I'm sorry.
What would you do, you goddamn punk?
Your previous job was beating people in debt because they didn't pay a loan back.
Oh, she's angry, guys.
I like her now.
That's really weird if you ask me.
We're just trying to spread some happiness here.
You think that's weird?
You make me sick!
Oh, you may have a point.
Oh, that's alright.
Okay, you- I understand, ma'am.
And don't you forget it!
Now that you're ignoring the only person other than me that wants to help you, let's go find some work!
This town is full of people that want to hire a mascot for an event.
We just don't know it yet.
The best bet is the shopping street.
Oh, okay.
Let's see who wants to hire Tofu.
Endo is the shopping association chairman.
He's another crusty old geezer, but he'll have work for us.
His office is in the covered shopping area.
He's always up early.
His wife gets him up and forces him out of the house.
Let's go.
Show me out when you need me.
I'm gonna go and find some mascots for you to recruit.
Peace!
Nice, alright.
I'm putting my recruitment out right now for mascots, guys.
Send your application.
I need a five-minute video that will show your personality and what your strengths are.
And you might get past the first stage to the interview stage.
A human-shaped missile who can not find it.
Okay, so that's the upgrade card.
And I got the pinky one.
Uh, alright.
And if you make it past the first stage, then you'll get an email from us at...
Uh, DokiCanRead at...
PromiseMascotAgency.
I went the wrong way.
I...
And then if you're really lucky, you might...
You might get into the second round of interviews.
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
I know the road is really big.
But I saw a man just smashed into the other light pole.
Alright.
Oh, that...
Oh, if I...
If I do well...
Then, like, the town will open more shops.
Ah, it's you.
Doki be like that, Endo.
Don't be like that.
I don't say Doki be like that.
Is this someone else you've accepted, Pinky?
You're damn right.
Oh, sorry, dear.
Some people have come to see me.
No, I'll be quick.
Oh, you're still whipped?
Please, keep your voice down.
Sorry, dear.
I was talking to someone.
Anyway, that last event we hosted to you...
Was a disaster.
Hey, that wasn't our fault.
You're the one to try to sift us on payment with a dodgy contract.
Nichi, this is
Endo.
He runs the shoppers' association in town.
He tried to scam us on a job.
Anyway, Endo.
We're back in business.
What?
I thought the mayor shut you down.
Business, business, business.
Endo's what?
I was like...
A man that's continued to put upon...
How is he expected to run a shopping association?
In a dying town?
How?
Just...
Open an Amazon warehouse.
The mayor agreed to let us reopen.
Speaking of wish, is it true you're planning on reopening all these stores?
Where did you hear that?
What is that?
Word is that you're finally getting some of that Kyoshi Rejuvenation Fund.
And you managed to convince people to reopen the old stores.
Yeah, what is...
What are the funds?
Some government subsidy.
For dying town like ours to revitalize tourism and industry.
No one has seen a single yen of it until now.
If you're opening stores, mascot events are an excellent way of promoting them.
I might need mascots, but I definitely don't need yours.
Sorry, dear.
I'll be done soon.
The mascot agency is under new management.
We're doing things differently now.
Pinky is taking less of a customer-facing role.
And we have a rising star.
Tofu.
My first generation.
We can help you turn this place around.
You know we can.
He has a really big fan base already.
Mr. Endo.
A book stop is about to open.
This is an old friend of mine, so please don't mess it up.
As a new store opens, I'll be in touch.
Just make sure you send good mascots.
You know what?
A tofu mascot will work great with this one.
Calm atmosphere for enjoying books.
They have a lot of comfortable sofas and houseplants.
I'll tell other business owners in this town that you're back in business.
Hopefully it will bring some people back to the shopping street.
We look forward to serving you.
See ya!
Told you it was a crusty old geezer.
May this humble dragon get a happy birthday, villain!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday...
I don't know why I forgot the birthday song for a second.
Happy birthday, dear villain!
Happy birthday to you!
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
I was like, what goes after happy birthday?
I was just like, what goes after that?
Oh yeah, another happy birthday.
Guys, I've been reading a lot.
And tomorrow is Super Mario Ma with more reading.
As long as you give us work, it doesn't matter.
What do you say, boss?
I'll take you through the next steps in the truck.
Alright.
Oh, I've got more fans!
You'll see notifications about job requests at the top right of the HUD.
The bar at the top left of the HUD shows you how many open job offers you have, and how many jobs are currently in progress.
Open the Magic Menu to view and accept your jobs.
The button prompt for the Magic Menu is on the top left.
It requires one mascot.
If you don't have any spare mascots, wait until one finishes your current job or find another one to recruit.
Job offers stick around, so don't worry about accepting them immediately if you don't have a spare mascot.
Jobs will have a preferred mascot type that they want.
Don't worry if you don't have a mascot of that type.
All that gets you is a bonus reward.
You can still do the job.
That'll make sense.
Wanna hear again?
Yeah, I'm good.
Awesome.
We should explore the town to look for more potential clients.
Wah!
More clients means more jobs, and more jobs means more yen!
People should be waking up now.
It is a lovely sunny morning to do some business.
Alright, Tofu.
Are you ready for your first job?
Okay, let me see.
Okay, uh...
Uh...
Alright, Tofu.
Has enough mascot, has the right type.
Oh my god, we're gonna get a bonus!
Yay!
We got 150 fans!
Nice.
Don't worry, Tofu.
They're gonna love you.
Alright, nice.
And then we should get more jobs now.
You just sent a mascot on the first job!
It's her first job, guys!
Her first stream!
She's debuting!
She's debuting now!
Right at the top of the business world.
Jobs take a certain amount of time to complete.
During that time, the basket is unavailable for any other work.
Jerry will get them to the job location and run the event on behalf of the client.
You can't take them to the event because you're supposed to be dead and events are streamed online.
Hopefully, everything will go well.
But if it does go sideways, Jory will give you a call to let you know.
You might have noticed the job has stamina requirement.
The event streamed a mascot to stamina, so if the mascot has low stamina, they can still go to the job but more likely to get in trouble.
Samma will replenish over time, so it's your call to let them rest or keep working.
That'll make sense, right?
Yeah, that makes sense.
Oh my god, we're at the gameplay part.
Finally.
We did it!
We're at the gameplay part!
Can I get more jobs from Endo?
Hey, I'm back!
Did you like it?
Do you like the mascot I sent over, Endo?
Oh, I can get us a...
You want to be a mascot support hero, do you?
I know you're a crusty old geezer, but I think you can help a mascot out.
You must have some life advice or something.
I'm not going to become a mascot support hero.
I'm not cut out for it.
Sorry.
We won't tell her.
I know you want to do it.
I can see it in your eyes.
A esteemed member of the community like yourself will be a huge help and inspiration to our mascots.
Well, you put it like that.
Good!
Glad to have you on board!
Thanks, Endo!
You guys are going to come to Tofu's debut, right?
Alright, nice.
I got the...
What's the town quest?
Is there anything else we can do to help with the business that are opening?
That depends.
Why does someone like you come to a town like this?
I want to build a successful business to do that.
I need a town to prosper.
Sorry.
This town has suffered for a long time.
Just keep working hard.
And hopefully, we can work together to improve the town and the businesses in there.
Alright.
Alright, we got the support card.
Oh, yeah?
Then why aren't you on her debut right now, huh?
Huh?
Yeah?
He's literally...
Oh wait, what's this?
Oh, it's a stamp!
Do I have to drive there?
Can I get out of my car?
I can't believe it.
Tofu's out there doing his debut?
And you're not even there to support him?
I can't believe it!
Alright.
Let's see.
Smash the old order.
Oh!
I got more fans for like...
For like running things over.
Wait, Tofu needs help!
What did you do?
Yes.
What is it?
We got a trump...
What did you do, Tofu Dachis?
I thought you were supposed to support...
I'm on a job, and this damn mascot has caused a mess.
Here's the deal.
If a mascot gets in trouble on a job, you need to decide whether you want to help them or not.
You need to choose to ignore the cry for help, but that's not very cool.
If you help them, you'll need to choose which heroes will best get them through their outer mean.
All the mascot events are streamed online, so I'll send you a link and you can watch this girl.
When the mascot gets in trouble, just choose which hero to use.
And hero manages to help the mascot.
To get your mascot out of trouble, and everyone goes home happy.
Oh my god, how did Tofu mess up his first...
His first debut!
His debut stream!
Oh my god, he was muted.
He was muted in his karaoke.
The mascot will still complete the job, but the client won't pay as much.
The mascot will also be unhappy and get fewer stat views since they messed up.
Anyway, boss man.
That's the deal.
Want me to go through again?
Alright.
Give me the...
Give me the stream link.
Oh my god, Tofu.
What's going on?
What's going on, Tofu?
What's going on in your debut stream?
I'm watching it right now.
Oh my god, there's 18 people watching now.
Welcome to another mascot event livestream!
I'm your host for today.
It's Mike Miller.
Okay.
It's...
It's Mike Miller.
What a...
What a name.
I may be in the studio in Tokyo by posting every livestream of every mascot event and every time.
Promise has opened and the mascot is already up to events.
Every event starts with a mascot handler introducing the mascot to the crowd.
Kusa.
WWW.
Promise mascot agency mascot handler is getting the audience ready...
Warmed up.
Ready for Tofu.
Here we go.
Tofu!
It's about to explode into the limelight.
Did you see that crowd is ready?
Anticipation is high.
Go Tofu!
Go!
What a small door.
How's the mascot supposed to fit through?
Stop laughing!
Looks like Tofu is in real trouble now.
Send in the heroes!
Versus normal sized door.
Press any key.
You'll need to overcome the obstacle.
What do I do?
By reducing its health?
Make sure you have...
Okay.
Happiest popularity total damage.
Oh!
Don't lose her!
Now your heroes will help the mascot.
Each hero deals damage.
They are strengths and weaknesses to different obstacle types.
What's the obstacle type?
Oh!
Wait, I'm playing a card game?
Your two actions lose when you run out of actions.
You haven't defeated the obstacle.
Um...
More cards when you play them.
Try to play a combination of cards that give you enough...
Actions and cards to defeat the obstacle and save the day.
Um...
Oh...
Plus one.
Oh, nice!
I got an extra turn!
The hero card costs...
So your remaining actions have been reduced by one.
You now have one action remaining.
Play your next card.
Um...
Plus 14.
Yeah!
We did it!
We saved it!
We overcome normal...
Those heroes really help.
We will not submit to tier in your small doors.
Good job, Tofu.
Oh my god!
And the view count is getting higher!
Let's go!
We're at 22 viewers!
He's a star.
He's gonna be my next star.
Let's go!
Good job, Tofu!
You have 22 new fans now!
Alright, good mascot, Tofu K.
Buffs.
Agency.
Hey boss, since this is the first job one your mascot has completed, I show you the detailed results.
Future results of completed jobs will appear.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god, he has potential.
You're right, guys.
First stream already, 22 viewers?
Good potential.
I'm gonna make him a star.
When a job...
Wow!
When a job is completed, you get rewards like money, new fans, and mascots improve their popularity.
You may also get some life satisfaction.
I need to tell you about something extremely important.
Go on.
If you're ever not sure what to do, you can hit the big old Ask Pickney button.
I've got loads of advice and thoughts on what you can do to improve the business.
However, I discovered people have extreme distaste for my unsolicited opinion.
So now, only give advice when you press that button.
Don't forget about that button.
You're wondering about this whole of a town without any idea what to do.
Have you got it?
Use the Ask?
Okay.
Yeah, I got it.
Good.
Some people still haven't used it despite me telling them quite clearly that they should.
Don't be like that, Michi.
Speaking of which, I got a bad feeling about jobs getting more difficult and us needing more heroes.
Won't you and Shiri be enough?
Our mascots are gonna step into the fires of hill.
Oh my god.
Tofu might step into a smaller door, guys.
What do I...
What do I do when they get through a smaller door?
Papa Smurf, thank you for Magenta Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
My Kami Oshi got announced at Offcut and then she introduced me to a bunch of new Oshi prospects on my birthday.
Thanks for all the presents, Doki.
Thank you for Magenta Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
And a happy birthday to you.
Papa Smurf, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Papa Smurf.
Yeah!
I get it.
What do we do?
There's a local hero called Captain Sign.
Let's go see him.
I'm marking this as a critical quest because this is hella important.
He hangs out on a weird wooden platform overlooking the town near the agency.
Let's go make some money and get you back in Shimazu's good books.
Alright.
Let's go make some money.
Okay, we gotta...
Okay, we gotta go this way.
Go and see Captain Sign.
Alright, what does the heart mean, though?
Alright.
No, we're not gonna ask...
Alright, we'll ask Pinky.
Huh?
What about mascots?
Let me check the message.
Shea said there's a goth mascot that hangs out at the graveyard?
The graveyard is near the rice field.
Oh, let's go!
Let's go get her.
Alright, where's the...
Oh, that's not it.
Wait, let's go to the goth mask.
Where's the graveyard?
Promise mascot.
Priest.
Creepy apartments.
Hot spring.
Wait, I wanna recruit a goth mascot.
People like that.
Abandoned tea farm.
Wait, where the fuck is the cemetery?
I assume like...
Mama-san.
I assume...
Wait, why is...
Is that just like a PNG of a real person?
This looks like a photo of a real person.
Mine's...
Creepy apartment.
Where the fuck is the cemetery?
Oh, it's...
Oh, there it is!
Oh, I'm so blind.
I'm so blind.
Alright, I see it.
Alright, let's go to the cemetery, guys.
I have to drive back to this bridge.
This is our first job.
I want a goth mascot in my agency.
But y'all get like...
One of each type.
To fit all the niches.
And all the tastes.
And I'll talk to you later, okay?
This is more important right now.
Oh, there's somebody's wallet.
Nice.
Yoink!
Alright.
Don't worry.
We don't need the rice here.
Is that the cemetery?
It's like above, right?
Oh, it's here.
Whoops.
It's fine.
The truck is indestructible.
Alright, where is she?
Wait, that's...
Oh.
Not gonna lie.
I thought...
She'd be a little hotter.
Um...
We can make it work.
We can...
We can make this work.
Yo, what's up?
She's perfect.
Whoa.
Okay.
I was not expecting that voice.
I...
Are you here for a tour?
Whoa.
A tour of what?
Wait.
I can see people...
When she makes her debut.
Can you say Aura?
Aura!
I'm the mascot currently taking care of...
Katsu.
Machi's ancient burial crown.
Can't understand and why...
Why people don't care about history more.
Underfunded and unhappy.
There's a graveyard mascot?
Okay.
Leave your job.
That's...
That's a pretty niche market.
That's what I was thinking.
I was like, how is this goth?
Green is the new goth.
Oh Samson, I'm just a tear-taker.
Keeping it all as presentable as I can by myself.
Who's employing you?
Is it the town hall or mascot work agency?
The town hall used to pay my wages for the tours, but there were budget cuts.
Some people at the town hall, if you ask me.
Jesus, her voice.
I'm gonna budget cut some people at the town hall, if you ask me.
I just couldn't stand by and watch the graveyard fall into ruins.
Like the rest of the town, so I'm doing it for free.
Okay.
Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do keep chat, so can you give us good dragoons and...
That's the source of the curse.
Are the spirits mad at us?
No.
Perfect.
Some are angry.
Some are understanding.
Some are lost.
They're individuals just like us.
Wait.
Are you from the mascot agency?
A rambuncious young lady named Shiori spoke to me earlier.
Yes, my name is Michi and this is Pinky.
Michi, really?
You got a problem with that punk?
You heard something you shouldn't have about the boss here.
Yeah, yeah.
The ladder.
That is horrifying.
Yeah, they're like...
Real...
It's like Fall Guys anatomy.
You know, like you think...
Like the...
You don't think about what's inside the bean.
But like they're actual things...
That are walking around.
Like...
They're real.
They're not like people inside a costume.
My name uses the same written characters.
No way.
That's lovely to hear.
Do you know of his poems?
He was completely enamored with plum trees.
And often featured them in his work.
There.
I can see from your tattoos that you have a connection with them too, Michi.
What do you have a connection with, Kofun?
The dead mostly.
And cats.
It tends to creep people out.
But Kasomachi is a place of limbo.
And I embrace it.
I will continue to promote and research the town's history.
And connect people with all the wonderful people that have lived here in the past.
We can use a mascot like yourself.
One who knows the town's history and strengths.
We're trying to cleanse the bad energy from this town.
Really?
We'll pay you to represent Kasomachi and help us settle the spirits.
And we need a mommy goth cat mascot.
For the fans out there.
Somebody is interested in that somewhere.
Time for change, darling.
We're gonna make the best mascot agency and crush Kiroshi under our foot.
There's definitely a market for that.
It's me.
I'm into that specific thing.
Green, goth, mommy, cat, mascot things.
No one wants a mascot shaped like a burial mound promoting their business.
Not even Kasomachi, the town of the dead.
They fired me, remember?
Cute mascots are all the rage now.
Don't worry, coffin.
We have...
What are her fans called, guys?
What are...
But I love goth girls.
Next to you, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
She's cute to me.
Don't let me worry about that.
We'll make them see sense.
Yeah, we're all about business deals.
Pie lunches, wireless headsets, and making dreams come true.
Don't worry.
The cadavers are here to support you, coffin.
Even though you're Yakuza?
I'm sorry, I always admire your tattoos.
They think you're cute, coffin.
What about the curse?
Why did you come to this town?
I won't let it get me until I'm done my job.
I will do it to my family.
And Kasomachi is the only place I can perform it.
Okay, I admire your determination.
Yay!
Alright, I'll give you...
5% And the time off.
Alright.
How about I give you that?
You get 8.
I don't know.
Who would make me more money?
Tofu or coffin?
Do we have like...
Big coffin fans that could...
Like...
Do we have like secret coffin or oiler...
Like cadaver oilers?
So that...
Justifies me giving her a bigger pay?
Tofu?
Okay, I'll give her a list of a share then.
Sorry.
But uh...
But you're not as popular as...
Oh yeah, your popularity is at 3.0.
You're right.
I'm sorry.
You don't have a...
Oh wait, but...
It's 750 fans!
Wait, she has more fans!
I dumped tofu for coffin!
You're right.
Alright.
I'll give you...
Okay.
I'm trying to...
It's fine.
She can have time off.
And then...
Trading!
She has potential.
I agree.
I think she might have potential to do more than tofu.
Alright.
Tofutachis, you're my public enemy now.
We'll do...
I'll make her a little bit more happier then.
Actually...
Oh my gosh.
She takes a bigger share too.
I'll do this.
Alright.
That's enough motivation.
She does have more fans.
Okay.
I would say she does have more fans.
So I'll give her a bigger share.
Loves to goff it up at the cemetery.
Alright.
Well...
Yeah, the more...
The better you do, the more pay I'll give you, coffin.
I'm gonna spread the history of Kasumachi far and wide.
And make everyone proud of this town.
Alright.
Are you guys a tofu dachi or a cadaver, guys?
What are you?
Do I have any jobs for her?
No.
Okay.
I don't have any right now.
Uh...
Crunch here.
I mean, they're all very satisfied.
Alright.
Let's see.
Where do I wanna go?
Uh...
Let's see.
Is there any other...
Any other...
Other mascots?
Tofu dachis for life.
There's a mechanic near...
He might be...
Oh!
Let's go see my...
Oh, okay.
Let's go see the mechanic.
And...
We'll see the mechanic, get a job, and then send...
We can send...
Uh...
Tofu...
No.
We can send coffin out to her first job.
I'm just a dragoon.
Wait, I hear money over here.
Money...
Alright, whatever.
I'll just grab this.
Eh...
It's just 800.
Uh...
Let's see.
Oop.
No, I didn't need advice.
I was trying to get the map out.
Uh...
Where is the mechanic?
Wait, why can't I move it?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Let's get to the mechanic.
220.
Doki's company seems to like...
Underpaying their...
Look!
They're just getting started!
Okay?
Uh...
My payment is merit-based.
So I need them to prove themselves before I give them a pay raise.
Thank you for this super chat.
Um, and...
Uh...
Thank you.
They just haven't proved themselves yet, guys.
I need to know if they're actually good at their jobs.
Oh, clean shrine.
We should clean the shrine.
Where do I get out of this?
Oh, I get 50 fans!
Nice!
Uh...
Provides a small bonus to the money earned from selling...
Oh!
Okay, we're gonna make merch soon.
Merch is like the biggest money maker...
For us.
Oh, let's park our car.
I want Koffin to make her big debut.
Hello!
Hey!
Get back here!
Wait, Jose?
Hahaha!
What is...
What's Jose?
Why do I...
Wait, why is his...
His name is Jose.
His name...
Wait, I don't know if you guys see it.
But you see the A.
What is Jose doing here?
Hahaha!
Aw, man.
What the...
What the heck is happening here?
He took my invention plans!
I'm sorry, can I help you, folks?
We're from the newly...
We're from the newly opened Promise mascot agency.
My name is Michi and this is Pinky.
Hajimemashite!
Hajimashite!
Pleasure to meet you.
I'm Jose Fujikawa.
Wait, but his last name is like...
Japanese...
Hahaha!
The happiest guy in town.
And a loving family man.
Looks like he could build anything.
He could be half...
Yeah, he could be half.
Oh, is he half Japanese?
What just happened?
The mountain spirits are angry with me.
Those foxes just took all of my invention plans.
Spirits are angry with you?
I like spooky stuff.
And years ago...
I heard some strange rumors about Kasomachi on the internet.
I went to investigate and ever since, the spirits have been angry with me.
Those foxes keep taking stuff from me.
Yeah, that's messed up.
It's...
Life is full of ups and downs.
I just need to offer something to the spirits.
Oh, he's so happy.
He's like a golden retriever.
This is perfect for coffin.
Don't give up!
Never give up!
What do the foxes take?
Well, I remember counting my day job.
But I also like to take care of my own time.
I came up with a few different methods to modify vehicles in new ways.
Go on!
Oh, those aren't really legal.
We are narcs.
Yeah, do we look like...
Do we look like cops to you?
Well, I found a new way to squeeze more performance out of old style engines like the one in your truck.
I also invented some stranger modification.
A launcher system controlled from the cab.
And a glider mode.
Just wait!
You said you can make a glide?
Wait, I can fly?
Oh my god, bro.
Pattern that shit!
Bro, I can have an actual flying car?
And act like a boat on water?
Bro, go fucking...
Go back to Tokyo and pattern that shit, buddy!
I can make your truck go faster.
What is he doing here in this village?
Let's you lodge projectiles and mod it to travel by sea and air?
What is this guy doing here?
Very efficient but not entirely legal.
Jose the goat.
This all sounds perfect.
This old truck is a piece of junk and it's about time it had some upgrades.
My truck is fine.
It doesn't need upgrades.
You don't even have a fucking phone, old man!
Don't listen to him.
He doesn't know what he's talking about.
I don't have whatever brain virus you have that makes you think that.
So trust me when I say...
Wrong!
You're wrong.
Bro, what is Jose doing here?
Nasa needs him.
No name, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, I don't know if you realize this but Nasa has had a lot of budget cuts.
I don't think Nasa can afford Jose.
This truck can barely make it up a hill.
It definitely can pick up hot babes or compete in drift races.
Gabriel, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There was a lot of Portuguese influences in Japan, historically speaking.
So that name wouldn't be impossible to find.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I didn't know that.
That's interesting.
Shut.
Oh!
Michi!
I know that you've replaced the intimate companionship in your life.
Oh!
Damn, Pinky!
Roast that fucker!
Whoa!
I know that you've replaced intimate companionship in your life with loving this truck.
But it's not cool.
You need help.
And if you ask me...
I didn't!
Shh!
She doesn't mean that.
Chuck-chan, she doesn't mean that.
We need to put more nitrous boost in here.
And get some kind of railgun to destroy obstacle.
And make this piece of junk amphibious!
No, we don't!
Hosee!
Hey!
Sure, my kids love mascots.
Besides, this place definitely needs a boost in business.
Okay, we just need to find his inventions.
Okay, but what if...
We specialize in tuning drift cars.
People from all over Kyoshi comes to see us.
Wait, maybe he's a single dad, guys.
You guys have a chance.
He didn't say anything about a wife.
Can you lead that to us, sweet stuff?
Oh, I can get...
Okay, I'm gonna skip the dialogue for this.
I'm...
Actually, I'm used to running around after my kids, so they're a little tears.
Sure, but I'll be a hero for you.
It's the least I can do.
You're gonna give me a chance to try out my inventions.
Yeah!
I got a loving family map.
It doesn't say he has a wife, guys.
Fine.
Nice, okay.
Okay, I wanna...
Thank you.
Those spear foxes could be anywhere.
Try it.
No, I want...
Keep pretty weird.
Why won't your wife be...
No!
He has a wife!
She puts up with me.
I love her.
Oh, my God.
And he said the L word.
I always get something in my head that I want to do.
And she just lets me do it.
I'm gonna kill myself.
Oh, my God.
The moment you hurt, it's over.
It's over.
He has a wife, guys.
Oh, my God.
Bro, that's wild.
Bro, you just met Jose.
Bro.
And he's...
And he's happily married, too.
What's the point?
He's happily married, guy.
Oh, shit, nice!
Okay.
We're sending...
It doesn't matter.
I don't care if we're sending you in.
Coffin.
Go do your job!
I believe in you, coffin!
Alright, it'll be fine.
Coffin will be fine.
Wait, there's a fox nearby?
I was not paying attention.
There's a fox.
I see no fox.
What do they even look like?
Wait, what do the foxes even look like?
I hear, like, noises here.
The white streaks?
What?
Oh, I see it!
I see it!
Is that where the spear fox is?
Okay, give me a sec.
I've been doing a lot of driving games lately.
Oh, I see it!
Is it that?
Oh, I think I see the fox!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, the little white streaks that's floating.
Oh my god, it's so fast.
Wait, they're so fast.
Wait, I lost them.
Wait, he's so fucking fast!
Oh my god, how do I catch... Okay, we gotta cut him off.
Nice, we ran over him.
Wait, he got away!
Wait, he fucking got away!
Wait, how do I... How do I catch him?
Wait, they looped.
Wait, he's gonna come back here.
Right here!
Then he, like, jumped over me!
All right.
And then...
Just jumped over me.
It's like, what!?
They sent down teeth to w- what?!
Oh, I need to jump.
Okay, okay.
Can't jump if I also jump.
All right.
All right, don't worry.
I got this.
He jumped even higher!
Why?
He just jumped higher!
Okay.
He double jumped.
Wait, that's illegal!
Okay, don't worry.
I'll come back.
Oh, Kofun needs help!
Kofun!
What happened?
Kavos are here!
It's Mike Miller.
Welcome to another event livestream, mascot fans.
Oh my god, she has 34 fans watching.
Oh my god, I knew you would be bigger than Tofu.
What's up with this dog?
Looks like he wants to play.
Okay.
Doesn't it know this is a mascot event?
It's nothing sacred?
The dog wants to play!
The dog wants to play during the goddamn mascot event!
Oh, damn!
Kofun's a cat!
And I sent him a cat mascot!
Unleash the heroes!
Noooo!
Dad, no!
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Um, plus ten.
Plus fifteen, all right.
Nice.
Guys, I have one remaining action, but I just need to do plus 10.
Here you go.
This should be enough.
Yes!
Get away from her!
We did it!
The dog just won half...
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
We're calming him down!
We did it!
We saved her debut, guys!
We did it, guys!
We did it, Kadaris!
We saved her debut!
Yippee!
Alright.
We're going to catch this fox.
I can do it.
If it's the last thing I'll do, I'll catch this fox.
That's my Oshi.
That's right.
Her debut is saved.
Like...
What?!
She just jumps higher!
I don't wanna... I don't wanna catch him!
Okay.
You have to catch him behind?
Oh my god!
I have to catch him from the... I actually have to catch him.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Okay.
He ain't gonna... He's not gonna get away from me.
That's right.
I did it!
Okay, I had to do it from behind.
Okay, Poseidon, call and tell him we found one of his plans.
Okay, we did it, guys.
I had to do it from behind.
Thanks for finding this.
No problem.
What's this one do?
This will give you some extra speed.
Getting more speed out of trucks like yours can be difficult.
However, I came up with a few hose modifications that should get you going faster.
Awesome!
I enjoy leisurely drives as much as the next person, but this truck could do with more juice.
Alright, I'll get it in some.
Yay!
We got speed!
Oh, and we have more fans!
They heard about my truck being the speediest...
The speediest truck in town.
Alright, guys.
Alright, let me save real quick.
I'm gonna call it here, guys.
Wait, how do I save?
How do I...
Oh, there we go.
Alright.
We're gonna save...
We're gonna stop it here.
That's fun, though!
That's fun!
It's a very interesting game.
It's definitely very narrative-driven.
So, it's definitely a nice change of pace on my other games.
But, my brain's tired from reading.
So, I'm gonna call it here.
Will you return?
Yeah, I'll play more of this.
I don't know if I'll play it all the way to the end.
But, definitely...
I'll try, like, one more part, and then we'll see how I feel.
And we'll do, like, one more part of this next week.
And then I'll...
Because I'm still...
Because we did a lot of, like, introduction.
Um...
We did a lot of, like, intro to it.
So, now we're actually in the meat of the game.
Like, we're slowly starting to get to the meat of the game.
So, I'm gonna see, like, the second part.
To see, like, how much of the gameplay we get after that.
And then I'll see how I feel.
And I want to keep going with this playthrough.
Um...
But it was very interesting.
Yeah.
It was very interesting.
And being able to, like, you know...
I can start my own VTuber company.
Uh...
Watch it!
Welcome to Tomato Fire!
Welcome!
Uh...
Next week, they give us Super Chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for reading all the voices, Doki.
I love hearing you voice act things.
It's a rare treat.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Also, cause, like, tomorrow, I also have another game...
Like, I'm playing Super Mario-Mond tomorrow.
And I also need to read a lot for that one.
So, I just want to make sure I rest my voice for tomorrow as well.
Because, you know...
Toad is in it.
And I don't...
I've never done a toad voice.
And I know that's gonna fuck up my voice eventually.
I'm like...
No!
Haha!
That's like...
That's my...
My...
My toad impression.
I'll be like, MARIO!
So...
Yeah, so...
Toad's in the game.
So I was like, okay, I need to rest my voice for tomorrow's adventure.
Hey guys, I'm gonna call it here.
As always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys tomorrow everybody, or I'll see you guys next time.
If you're not gonna be there tomorrow.
Bye guys!
Bye!